- Yeah, there's a very like,
hello, would you like to buy a car
element to that.
(funky music)
I pretty much only ask
people out over text.
- I know I've never called
someone to ask them out.
- The only people I call
on the phone are like
my mom or,
that's it.
- In middle school I
would talk on the phone
with this girl I had a crush on.
- It was like the kind
of dance when it was
girls ask the guys out.
- You can look at a text
and then kind of reply
on your own leisure,
but when you're on the phone
you can hear their response.
(funky music)
- I met him about a month ago
when I went bowling and I
thought he was really cute
and I thought he was really funny.
- I'm just gonna ask out someone
who I met two nights ago.
We had a good conversation,
she might be at work,
so that could be a problem.
- We were in the same dorm last year.
He really likes soccer and basketball,
I love soccer and basketball.
We both love anime.
This guy is kind of a perfect guy.
- This girl that I went
to high school with
and throughout college we kind of
went back and forth on saying
that we should catch up.
- I have a crush on them
for a very specific reason,
that I'm not gonna say on the internet.
- Contemporary American
Fair and Mixology focused
cocktails in the mid-century
modern space of the patio.
- I'm available next Friday,
I wanted to know if you wanted to go out.
With me.
If you'd like to go out with me.
- Well, if he doesn't pick up,
I think it would be rude
to leave it in a voicemail.
- Frogs like licking
you 'cause you're fly,
let's go to the beach.
I dunno.
- The worst thing that could happen
is someone says no to me.
I'll move on.
I'll write about it in my journal.
I'll go to therapy about it.
I'll be fine.
I think.
- Here we go.
- I haven't gotten these kinds of
ringtones in a long time.
(phone ringing)
(humming along to ring back tone)
- [Woman] Hi there, this is (beeps),
I can not make it to
the phone at the moment.
- Voicemail.
- Please leave.
- Hi, (beeps), it's Katherine.
Yeah, it's been a while.
How have you been?
- How are you?
Good, how's your day goin'?
- Hey, (beeps) what are you up to?
Well, I mean, just in general,
but yes, are you busy?
- Just got back from work,
that's cool, that's cool.
Work is fun.
- Hey, (beeps) this is Rocky,
I was just hanging out listening
to that Giant Dog album
you've been telling me about--
(fast forward sound effects)
So, I wanted to say that
I'm available next Friday,
and I was wondering if
you'd like to go out.
So, you can call me back or text me.
- You bought your own bowling ball?
- Just chilling on the couch.
You know, doin' what I do,
just hangin' out at work.
- This is Jordan the ginger
dude you met at the mixer
a couple nights ago.
I thought you were pretty
cool and pretty cute
and I would love to
take you out for a drink
some time next week.
- I just finally built up the confidence
to ask you on a date,
so I was calling to see if you wanted
to get drinks some time.
- Hey, I've wanted to ask you a question.
When you come to LA,
if you wanted to like,
go to the beach you know,
or go play some soccer on the beach
and watch some Avatar: Last Air Bender,
Legend of Korra,
I dunno, just hang out and stuff.
- I was wondering if,
I'm sorry, I'm being really weird.
Do you wanna like, go out sometime?
Like--
Okay, cool, yeah.
We could.
Yeah, cool.
Cool.
- Right now I'm free Monday or Tuesday,
you give me a call back if you're free.
Thanks, bye.
- Oh, this is not Netflix
and chill per say.
- Hope you're having a good
day and a good year so far
and talk to you later.
Bye-bye.
- Well, as a date.
No, dude, that's fine, okay.
- Not Netflix and chill
but Netflix and just begin.
Netflix and just have fun,
but not sexual fun.
What?
- All right, cool.
Awesome.
Well,
I just have a little bit of a cold,
I don't normally sound this high pitched.
- Hey, sounds good!
Cool!
All right.
- I just got friendzoned.
It's cool.
Awe, now you guys are making me sad.
Wait.
- Voicemail, yeah.
There was a bit of that kind of relief
and then intense anxiety of
oh, now you have to do a monologue
that will stand on its own.
- He said yes!
- Woo-hoo!
Yeah!
Now I feel really good!
- I don't feel like I
get the same satisfaction
as someone who's like,
okay, I either get an
acceptance or rejection,
now it's just like--
(funky music)
- [Voicemail] If you're
satisfied with the message
press one, to listen to
your message press two,
to erase and re-record press three.
To continue recording--
Message erased.
(funky music)